going to start this first monday of the
new year with a travel mess thousands of
air passengers are still trying to get
home after the holidays amid major covet
and weather delays the weather a winter
storm is pushing through washington d.c
right now forcing more flight
cancellations today and that follows a
storm that dumped half a foot of snow on
chicago and other parts of the midwest
over the weekend the stormy weather and
the continuing spread of the omicron
variant was bad news for travelers left
waiting in long lines at the airport and
the airport is where we find our arrow
barnett reagan national airport outside
washington errol good morning
good morning this airport is the
national sore spot right now as this
winter storm marches its way east snow
forecast here throughout the morning and
it's just one aspect of a major
disruption to air travel which has been
taking place since christmas you've got
high demand covered outbreaks plus
inclement weather equaling passenger
pain
the perfect storm of extreme weather and
a resurgent covid combined to strand
passengers across the country after the
holidays on sunday more than 2700
flights were canceled along with more
than 9 000 delays it was a similar
picture on saturday travel analyst henry
hardevelt what's amazing is this is
affecting all airlines many airports
it's a mess on a mess on a mess
chicago's o'hare airport was the worst
affected on sunday with more than 500
flights almost half of those scheduled
canceled or delayed as long as i'm not
spending a night here i'm good
the travel chaos comes as the industry
struggles with staffing shortages
brought on by increasing covert
infections hundreds of bags lined up at
denver international airport due to a
lack of ground crews with an offer from
southwest to pay passengers a travel
credit if they picked up their bags and
returned hours later in fairness to the
airlines they've had a spate of bad
weather which creates its own set of
problems they've had covet which is
randomly affecting
all of their workers including pilots
flight attendants and others
ashley hernandez has been trying to get
home to phoenix from los angeles for the
past three days my flight got canceled
three times already and it was due to
lack of crewmates and now she's crossing
her fingers that the fourth time is the
charm there's already been a text saying
that they're 45 minutes delayed it is
just a nightmare now more than 1700
flights are scheduled to be cancelled
today we could see that number creep up
some airlines have proactively cancelled
flights over the next few weeks like jet
blue but we're also seeing these covered
outbreaks extend to air traffic control
towers across the country as well with
the faa telling cbs news we should
expect reduced traffic at some airports
in order to maintain safety
oh man errol thank you very much covet
surge and bad weather not a good combo
thank you very much